well there are a lot of great things
happening here in st. Louis the chess
campus as we call it so many different
activities a US Championship to be sure
top level games but a lot of youngster
young activities that is for the youth
here in st. Louis and Bryan caseta who
is a professor at the University of
Missouri is part of the team doing some
research on all the great scholastic
efforts that are being done here Brian
welcome to the show tell us what you do
right now in Missouri well I'm a
professor at the University of Missouri
I study education policy so I'm in the
Department of Economics in the School of
Public Affairs there and specifically we
look at education policies my specific
research agenda I'm really interested in
things that engage students and make
students give them opportunities that
they don't necessarily have this is
ranged from studying the effects of arts
education education q manatees after
school programs field trip programs so
working with the Chess Club is a natural
fit because this is a-you know the
scholastic program here in st. Louis is
a perfect example of the type of program
that can bring students something that
they can't access in any other way now
you mentioned that you've done all these
different sorts of activities why is
chess such a natural match for the kind
of things that you're doing well I think
one of the most fascinating things about
chess is that it really seems to hit two
specific areas that we care a lot about
one is the academic component I mean
chess naturally translates to things
like spatial reasoning and math skills
there's been some studies that have come
out of Europe that show that students
who play chess are better at math their
math scores go up particularly study in
Italy study in Denmark and that's
obviously something that we care about
but that's not the only thing we care
about we also want students to be
engaged at school we want them to be
intrinsically motivated to learn and to
take on challenges and to build their
confidence chess has that component as
well if you can get students to have fun
while they're learning you've you've
really figured out a way to you know
crack that nut and move the needle now a
lot of people want to see numbers they
want to see that there are concrete
results not just anecdotal evidence to
prove that chess is great for kids even
though we all know chess is fantastic
for course but what has a the number
said you're the research guy what have
you seen to be just really credible
numbers that suggests that it's chess
that we should be incorporating into our
nation's schools
well there have not been you know any
big large-scale research studies in the
United States to date there's the
European studies where you know there
are you know countries in Europe that
shows where chess is part of the
curriculum those studies have mainly
focused on academic and achievement
effects and they've found like I said
typically increases in math achievement
the research that we've done so far to
date and st. Louis and in you know some
of the schools in Ferguson is we're
looking at the more of the student
engagement questions and we've piloted
surveys with the students that are in
the clubs with some pretty you know
overwhelming you know feedback that
we're getting from these students in
terms of the way that they view the Tres
program so for example we've we've had
the the feedback surveys have shown that
more than 90 percent of these students
agree that chess makes them more
confident that they can accomplish
difficult difficult tasks makes them
want to challenge themselves more in the
future and I think probably the one that
you know gives us some of the most
confidence is 85% of the students in
these programs say that they look
forward to coming to school more on days
when they have chess and that's huge
because getting getting kids to school
is is you know sometimes one of the
hardest things that's right in chess day
for my students is usually a key day
they want to get out of bed it's like
okay we're gonna be playing chess with
mr. Ashley today so they're usually
pretty happy about that now we're
working on a project together along with
other members of the team dr. Matthew
pepper Tony and Kareem both Tony's a
bunch of Tony Chen and Richard pointer
and we are having a great time we're
putting together this curriculum tell
the folks some details about what we're
doing in this effort right so we know
when you get involved with research
there's really you know two important
points here one is certainly we want to
know what the impact is we want to know
what the outcome is but implementation
is huge you know there was a big study
in England recently that did not find
positive effects from
but that study came out and reported
that implementation may have been the
problem in that maybe the teachers
weren't prepped properly they didn't
have enough resources and materials so
we're focused a lot right now with you
on designing making sure that
implementation is right in four key
areas so we're devising a set of
standards that are going to be
competency-based that sequentially sort
of walk students through you know the
beginning day of you know how to set up
a chessboard all the way to eventually
being a grandmaster like yourself we're
working on curricular materials that
will be attached to those standards so
the instructors here at the Chess Club
have the tools that they need to engage
those students we're looking at a lot of
digital options things that students can
use on tablets and their phones we're
gonna build in a framework for
assessments so the instructors can
monitor the students progress know where
the gaps are know where they need to
target their efforts and then a final
component is working really on the
certification of the chess instructors
to make sure that before they go out
into the classroom they have everything
that they need and they're ready to go
that is so thorough you studied so
perfectly and it's going to be an
amazing effort I can't wait and for us
to finish this job and release it to the
world and everybody see what we're doing
here and say Lois Brian thanks so much
for being a colleague look forward to
doing some more work with you thank you
very frank casita at the University of
Missouri helping the transform chess not
just here in st. Louis but around the
country